Well, good morning church.
It's great to see you. If you're new here,
my name is John, one of the pastors here.
We would love to get to know you if you are new.
Uh, there's a QR code on the seat in front of you.
You can fill that out, just simple form online
or you can take that card out to the lobby
to our new here area just to get to know us so we can get
to know you a little bit better.
There's also a great way for you if you are newer
to our church or maybe you've been here for 40 years,
either way to get
to know a little bit about what's going on in our church.
We're having a church family meeting next Sunday
afternoon from three to five.
Invite all of you to be there, uh, old or new.
We would love to have you because it's a great time for us
to celebrate what God has done, to pray for what he's doing,
and to look ahead really to some cool things
that we believe God is doing
and wants to do through our church.
And so that's next Sunday.
But finally, just briefly let me mention this.
If you are at all worried over the next couple weeks in your
own life, your family, about food insecurity
or how bills are gonna be paid just based on what's going on
in our culture right now, we would love
to have you call the offices.
We can point you to resources.
We've got some, there's others in the
community we can help you with.
Okay? So if that's at all on your mind, if you're worried,
please don't stop and don't hesitate to call the offices.
We'd love to help you. So today we are nearing the end
of our journey through first and second Samuel.
Just a couple weeks left.
We've seen a couple kings now rise and fall,
and all of it has pointed us to looking forward from
that point in history, looking forward to the true
promised King that we now know Jesus to be
as we get into it today.
Uh, lemme tell you about one of the most irrational fears I
had when I was a kid.
Uh, I, I guess just how many people talked about it,
the way people talked about it.
I was certain that I would encounter quicksand way more
often than I have in my life, like terrifying
and just thought maybe I would still,
maybe I thought I was gonna be Indiana Jones
or something like that and just have the quicksand
and snakes and all that stuff, but I, I know it's real.
But the, the fearsome thing about quicksand is
that it traps you
and the more you move while you're in it is,
is making it suck you more
and more into its hold into the mire that the quicksand is.
There's a way out. It's not gonna just drown you.
There's a way out, but you need help to get out
of the quicksand.
Isn't it interesting that your past
can function a lot like quicksand?
See, we can get trapped in the cycle of regret
over what we've done
and that whirlpool can suck us into a really dark place.
When that guilt monster creeps onto your shoulders based on
what you've done as you think back, you know what happened,
it can block the light of God's mercy
And it can lead to further compromise.
Like you almost can't even think about God loving you
or God's mercy, a grace to you,
and it can lead you to further steps down that dark road.
See, my hope today here as we look at David, deal with
that same situation, my hope today is that
each of us can be awakened
to the solution
That God offers us.
Because the reality is every one of us are gonna be in
that state at some point.
Maybe you are even right now.
What solution does God offer us?
And so I wanna just pray
that God would teach us open our hearts and minds.
Lord, thank you for your word.
And we pray that as we look at Second Samuel again today,
that you would teach us
and remind us of what we need to remember
as we follow you in a world
and in our lives that is all about dredging up the past
and, and maybe the enemy is right now on somebody tapping
their shoulder saying, Hey, remember, remember God,
show us today what you want to show us
that we can walk in freedom for your glory,
for our good, for others.
Good. In Jesus' name, amen.
So where we left off in chapter 18 last week is
that David's son who was trying
to steal the throne from David Absalom, he was now dead
and David was grieving deeply over the loss.
And so we see it here in chapter 19 verses one through four,
this continuation of his grief,
two Samuel 19 verse one, it was told Joab,
behold the king is weeping and mourning for Absalom.
And so the victory that day was turned into mourning
for all the people.
For the people heard that day,
the king is grieving for his son.
And the people stole into the city that day
as people steal in who are ashamed when they flee in battle,
The king covered his face
and the king cried with a loud voice.
Oh my son, Absalom. Oh Absalom, my son, my son.
So at that time, what
to some would've felt like a victory march
that this rebel is now gone.
The rebellions quenched what them
to them should have felt like a victory march
that David's back on the throne that was quenched
by the way, David was responding, A day of deliverance
turned into a day of shame for David's army.
Now, let's not minimize
how terrible it would be to lose a son.
I can't imagine what I would feel
like David would feel here, but,
but why was David mourning like this in
what maybe even seemed like an over the top kind of way?
Why was he so grieved that he couldn't even function
because he knew the terrible truth that
he was the ultimate cause of this whole thing?
Remember his sins against Bathsheba
and against Uriah all the way back in chapters 11
and 12 that brought judgment on him
and his family, the sword would not depart from his house.
Here's evidence. And
so David is feeling not only the grief of losing a son,
he's feeling the the consequence
of the responsibility he felt for it.
Well, watch how Joab, the commander
of David's army responded.
Look at verses five through seven,
then Joab came into the house to the king
and said, you have today covered with shame.
The faces of all your servants
who have this day saved your life and the lives of your sons
and your daughters, the lives of your wives, your con mines,
because you love those who hate you
and hate those who love you.
For you've made it clear today that commanders
and servants are nothing to you for today.
I know that if ab some were alive
and all of us were dead today, then you would be pleased.
Now therefore arise, go out, speak kindly to your servants
for I swear by the Lord.
If you do not go, not a man will stay with you this night.
This will be worse for you than all the evil
that has come upon you from your youth until now.
Hard words, right? Like offensive words in
some way to David.
But true words.
See, David's guilt had become so consuming
that he could not see God's hand
of preservation for his family.
And it appeared to everyone that he loved his rebel son
who tried to kill him,
yet at the same time hated the faithful servants
who protected his life
and risked their own lives to protect David.
I mean, that's what it looked like to everybody else.
But this is what unresolved guilt does.
It corrupts your affections and it blinds you to grace.
And so David had a choice to make at this point.
Was he gonna continue in this grief
and continue to lose his army
and they were gonna run off and he was gonna be alone?
Is he gonna continue in that or is he gonna get up and lead?
Well look at verse eight. Then the king
of arose and took his seat in the gate, a place
where he led from.
And the people were all told,
behold the king is sitting in the gate
and all the people came before the king.
He awakened to his responsibility.
He didn't feel better.
He didn't have closure, but he obeyed.
He obeyed God. He knew this was his
responsibility as the king.
And so he chose to honor God's deliverance even while his
heart was shattered at the loss.
David's paralyzing grief over Absalom
nearly turned God's gracious victory
into catastrophic defeat
until this fierce rebuke awakened David to reality.
Here's the point, church, don't let your
past consume God's mercy today.
Like don't let your past are.
Are you so consumed by guilt over past
sins that you can never receive God's mercies today?
Are you in that quicksand of regret
where you're just thinking right now God doesn't love me?
Like is that in your mind? God doesn't love me?
Listen, that's not humility you.
You could get it wrong in your head to think, well,
I'm being humble that somehow God doesn't love me.
That's not humility. That's actually a form of pride
that says you've done more than everybody else ever has
house and you can't receive God's mercy
because of the past.
You're guilty over her.
And so what I'm saying to you today, confess your sin,
accept God's cleansing
and then get up and serve him.
Don't let it paralyze you your guilty conscience.
Don't let it paralyze you from the calling God has
given you today.
It might be a different calling than it was before
because of your sin, but still get up and obey.
God,
as I talk about this, I think about one
of Jesus's closest disciples.
His name was Peter. If you remember Peter boldly said
on the night before, Jesus was crucified
that he would never deny Jesus.
Yet just a couple hours later, he denied he even knew Jesus.
Well, there's a little detail to the scene
that we often just skim over.
It's recruited, recorded in in Luke 22.
I want you to listen to this.
This is when Peter, he denied Jesus the third time
around this charcoal fire.
He's he's saying, I don't even know the guy.
I don't even know the guy on the third time,
he denies Jesus.
Watch what happens. And the Lord turned
and looked at Peter
and Peter remembered the saying of the Lord, how he had said
to him before the rooster crows today,
you'll deny me three times.
And he went out
and wept bitterly like,
can you imagine the grief Peter would've felt in
that moment, the regret he would've lived with
as he watched his best friend go get crucified
and buried knowing
that he should have stood up for him and he didn't.
He said, I don't even know the guy.
That's part of what makes the end of John's gospel so
powerful because
after Jesus was resurrected, he came
and found his disciples on the shore of the lake
and he made them breakfast and he's cooking this breakfast
and, and as Peter drew near to Jesus, I am sure
that the smell of the charcoal fire
flooded some memories back into Peter's mind Of
what would've happened just a couple days earlier
around a charcoal fire as well
where he denied he even knew Jesus three times.
Yet here's what Jesus did on that beach. Here's what he did.
He sought Peter out
and he gave Peter the opportunity to reaffirm his love
for Jesus by Jesus affirming his love for Peter.
And how many times did Jesus repeat that question in
that conversation three times.
How many times did Peter deny Jesus three times?
See the grief that Peter would've felt could have
overwhelmed him, it could have kept him from
continuing to follow Jesus.
It could have hindered his acceptance of God's mercy.
And he could have walked off
and said, I don't want anything to do with you Jesus anymore
because I know I'm so dirty you could never love me again.
But instead, Jesus met him where he was
and he showed Peter Mercy,
hear me friend, walk into that light today.
Walk into that light today. You're not unlovable.
You're not too far gone.
Don't let your past consume the mercy that God wants
to lavish on you today.
There's another way that David's guilt showed up though
here in Second Samuel.
It had to do with Joe ab, his military commander.
If you remember last week, David explicitly told his army,
nobody touch Absalom Joab
though explicitly disobeyed
and took Absalom's life.
Now, sadly, that wasn't the first time
that Joab had killed a
rival back in chapter three.
It was Abner. It will happen again here in chapter 20
with a man named Amasa.
But here's the, here's what David knew about Joab.
David knew that Joab was ruthless, he was ambitious
and he was disobedient.
And David understanding that did nothing about it.
David did nothing about it. Why?
Because Joab was David's accomplice
in taking Uriah's life when he was
trying to cover up his sin.
He was who he sent to the front lines
with the message right?
Saying, Hey, let's get Uriah back and all these things.
And knew what happened.
On the other side of that, when Uriah went back
to the battle, Joab knew too much.
David was trapped by his past.
Now, I'm not saying David didn't try to do some things
to deal with this here in chapter 19.
He just tried to replace Joab with this man named Ammas.
And initially it seemed to work like I'm just gonna remove
Joab and Ammas is gonna be my military commander now.
And it seems like everything is fine until Joab just went
and murdered Amsa and took his job back.
Yet again, David said nothing. David did nothing.
He could not execute justice
because his hands were tied by guilt.
Listen, this, this is the terrible bondage of secret
Sin.
It gives wicked people power over you
and it makes you complicit in evils that you should condemn.
And it's interesting you track
David's life, we won't get there.
It's past end of second Samuel.
It wasn't until David's deathbed that he did anything about
Joab, which isn't even anything
because this is what One Kings chapter two says.
This is David talking.
Moreover, you also know what Joe ab, the son of Zeriah did
to me, how he dealt with the two commanders of the armies
of Israel, Abner, the son of Ner
and Amasa, the son of Jeer whom he killed avenging in time
of peace for blood that had been shed in war,
putting the blood of war on the belt around his waist
and on the sandals of his feet,
meaning he's just a ruthless man.
Now, David says this, this is, he's talking
to his son Solomon, who's now going to be the king.
He says, act therefore, according to your wisdom,
but do not let his gray head go down to Sheol in peace.
So basically what David does on his deathbed is saying,
Hey Solomon, you're the king.
Now you deal with this.
David was the king for decades
and he didn't do anything about it.
He says, Solomon, now you're the king. You deal with this.
So for decades, David lived under the shadow of a man.
He couldn't discipline because of shared guilt.
Like what? Waste, what compromise.
That's the point here, church, listen, do not let your past
compromise God's plan.
It can consume God's mercy.
You can't feel loved by God,
but it also can compromise God's plan in your life.
Don't let your past compromise your ability to follow
and obey what God wants you to do right now.
What is God telling you? What is he commanding you?
Don't let your past compromise that.
Just, just think about this for a second.
What sins in your past
are giving someone power over you today?
What compromises are you making
because you're afraid of
what could get exposed if you said anything about it?
Listen, you cannot serve God faithfully
by being blackmailed by your past.
You're always gonna be stuck.
You're always gonna be compromised in your ability to obey.
And so what do you do with it? You bring it into light.
You confess it fully.
You break the power that guilt has over you.
That's why I love what one John one says how he says it.
One John one, seven through 10, listen to this.
If we walk in the light as he is in the light,
we have fellowship with one another
and the blood of Jesus, his son cleanses us from all sin.
If we say we have no sin, we deceive ourselves.
And the truth is not in us.
If we confess our sins, he's faithful
and just to forgive us our sins,
to cleanse us from all unrighteousness.
If we say we have not sinned, we make him a liar.
And his word is not in us.
We can't stand here, walk around, sit in a group
and say, no, I'm good.
None of us can. We're lying.
We're making him a liar who said, no, you're all sinners.
So let's just be okay with that.
Like not okay with it in the sense
that we're gonna continue, but like we should be able
to say, yeah, I'm broken.
Yeah, I have sinned. And here's what it just said.
Did you see Christ's blood doesn't just forgive?
It also frees you from sins quicksand.
So you can live in righteousness without fear of accusation.
It cleanses you from all sin.
And I know, listen, I know some of the stories in this room
that you're sitting there like I was 20 years ago,
that the longer you let it go on
and don't say anything about it, the harder
and more painful it is to confess it.
I understand. But you cannot
walk in the freedom
that Christ offers you if you keep hiding it.
So friend, walk into that light today.
Walk into the light. You're not defined by your past.
If you're in Christ, you're not defined
by somebody else's past.
If you're in Christ, you can walk into the light
and you can be free in Christ.
There's one more thing that this passage should remind us
of today, and it points us from their perspective.
Points us forward. See, we know from what,
what, uh, David did in Second Samuel.
He confessed it, right? We have Psalm 51.
He confessed the sins against Bathsheba and Uriah.
And in second Samuel 12,
the prophet Nathan pronounced forgiveness.
But the consequences continued.
The guilt lingered. The compromises multiplied.
Why? Because the old covenant
sacrifices could never take
away sins.
It's what Hebrews 10, four says, that it is impossible
for the blood of bulls and goats to take away sins.
That's what David would've done in, in light of his sin,
he would've sacrificed a bunch of things and and,
but it could never take it away.
And then they had to repeatedly offer the same sacrifices
each year, each year, each sin, each sin.
They had to keep doing that.
All that didn't work
because those sacrifices were a mere shadows.
They were pointing forward to something greater.
David needed what he didn't have.
Yet he needed a sacrifice
powerful enough to actually clean the conscience.
It would take away the eternal effect of sin.
That's why they were doing that in the sacrifices.
But as Hebrews nine 14 says, how much more will the blood
of Christ who
through the eternal spirit offered himself without blemish
to God, purify our conscience from dead works
to serve the living God?
See, that's what David needed and that's what you
and I need to be reminded of every day.
Here's the truth. Your past is cleansed by Christ's blood.
Your past, if you are in Christ, is cleansed
by Christ's blood.
That's what one John one seven said. Remember that?
It said The blood of Jesus cleanses us from all sin,
not merely covers it,
not merely just hides it, it cleanses it.
It removes it completely from our lives.
And listen, I know right now even
or today, later or tomorrow or tonight
or the next week, I know the enemy is gonna sit there
and just come after you over and over and over.
He's accusing you of all the things
you've done in your past.
And I want you to be honest with this, right? He's right.
You did all that stuff, didn't you?
If you sit there and said, no, I didn't do that.
He's like, I got the receipts right here, man.
He's gonna accuse you. He's going to say,
you did this, you did that.
You did this, you did that. And you have to say, yep, I did.
That's why one John two is such good news.
'cause listen to this one John two
verse one, my little children.
I'm writing these things to you so
that you may not sin, I guess the goal.
Oh, but if anyone does sin,
we have an advocate with the Father,
Jesus Christ, the righteous.
And verse two goes on to say
that He is the propitiation for our sins.
A big theological word that means the all sufficient
payment for our sins.
The sacrifice of the Old Testament
could never take away sins.
Jesus, the propitiation that is sufficient.
He did take away sins.
That means, hear me, the guilt is gone,
the debt has been paid, the conscience is purified,
and you are now free to serve the Lord without fear
of accusation, without shame of your past.
Why? Because the perfect blood of Christ was shed for you.
This is the problem David couldn't solve.
And this is the problem that your good works can't solve.
This is the problem that your church attendance can't solve.
This is the problem that your morality can't solve.
The only path forward out of sin and guilt
and shame is through the blood of Christ, through the life,
death, and resurrection of Jesus in your place.
That's the only way out of sin and guilt and shame.
And so hear me today.
If you are in Christ, stop punishing yourself for sins
that Christ has already covered.
Amen. He's already carried those.
You don't have to carry those anymore.
Stop living under the shadow of guilt
that his blood has already covered.
There'll be grief, there'll be consequences,
yes for your sin.
But Romans eight, one says, there is now no condemnation
for those who are in Christ Jesus.
Like there's guilt and consequence, yes,
but there's no condemnation.
There's no shame anymore if you are in Christ
because of his blood shed for you.
We often, when we read through the Bible, we get to the end
of the Old Testament and there's all these,
what they call minor prophets, a lot of prophecies,
a lot of hard things and images,
and it's really difficult to understand at times.
And so we kind of skate over those
and don't really get into what's there.
But one of my favorite scenes in the whole Bible
is found in the often overlooked prophet named Zechariah.
I wanna briefly paint the picture for you.
It's in chapter three. You can read it later.
But there's this vision, Zechariah receives.
And in this vision, he sees Joshua, the high priest,
standing before the angel of the Lord, kind of
before the throne of God, you might say in a sense.
And and Joshua is clothed in just these filthy robes.
Like his clothes are just nasty.
He's dirty, he's standing before God,
and he's in these dirty clothes.
And it's this picture of sin, guilt, stained leadership
and a lot of that involved.
But, but just imagine that picture.
And Satan, the enemy of our souls, is standing right next
to him, ready to accuse Joshua of all the past,
all the nasty, all the guilt, all the things.
But what's interesting is that God does not
minimize the filth.
Like God doesn't look at, ah, it's not that bad.
He doesn't say that. Instead, this is what God commands.
And the angel said to those who are standing
before him, remove the filthy garments from him.
And to Joshua, he said, behold,
I have taken your iniquity away from you,
and I will clothe you with pure S
pure closed, clean, closed.
Listen, is that not a picture of grace?
Like God doesn't ignore your sin.
He actually removes it
and replaces it with something spotless,
with something pure.
He takes away our sinful heart of stone
and he gives us a heart of flesh
so we can have a relationship with him, so we can love him,
so we can obey him.
He takes away our filthy rags of life that we've lived,
and he cloth us with the perfect blood of Jesus.
That's what David needed, and that's what we need.
Because You saw what happened when David had unresolved
guilt and unconfessed sin and all the consequences piled up.
You saw what happened when that's the way we live our lives.
But when Christ's blood shows us something infinitely
better, he shows us something
that we can't have any other way.
He shows us total forgiveness, complete cleansing, the power
to serve God with a clean conscience.
When all of that is seen, listen,
don't waste another day mourning over sins
that Jesus has already carried to the grave.
The blood of Christ is sufficient.
So walk in it, rejoice in it,
and be free in it today.
Listen, here's how we're gonna respond.
There is no better picture of what
that just told us than the Lord's Supper.
When you hold those elements of
juice and a cracker, they're meant to illustrate
the broken body
and shed blood of Jesus for you.
And so if you're serving Lord stuff, I wanna go ahead
and ask you to go ahead and begin to serve that,
because that means people are gonna be moving around.
And I don't want that to happen here in
a second for what we're gonna do.
And so as they're preparing, this is for believers.
If you are a follower of Christ, if you said,
Jesus, I need you in my place.
I need your blood to cover my sin. This is for you.
But here's what I want us to do.
While we're receiving the elements for the next few minutes,
I talked a lot about guilt.
And I know because I'm just like you,
that there's stuff that there's,
that's cropping up in your soul right now.
There's things that you have dealt with and are dealing with
and and I just want this moment to be quiet for you,
to receive those elements
and to reflect on
who Jesus is and what He's done for you.
So as you receive the elements, let's reflect quietly.
Maybe your head bowed, eyes closed, just you
and Jesus taking time to deal with where you are in that.